Hey guys, it's Sean and it's getting hot out, so I'm going to make some lemonade and do some hats that I'm going to be selling. So if you want to block your face from the sun or somebody you don't like, come on down and buy a hat. Welcome to Smart List. Jason came over the other day on Sunday to watch little football and he brought young Maple with him to hang with the boys. First thing he does, every time he comes over, he goes straight to my fridge and then to my pantry to walk me through to shame me for whatever food I've got in the house. A lot of material.
But then so much of it, it's dripping with jealousy. He's trying to shame me for my food. How about the three pizza boxes that were in the pantry? There's only you and two young boys that live in that house. There were three large pizzas, one of which, thank God, wasn't even eaten the following day. Just sitting there on the countertop. Well, first of all, we have more than that. We have, there are at various times four boys in this house, A. And B, we like to try different pizza and then we eat it over the course of days and we put it in the fridge and we have pizza one day a week. So you're not polluting them with just one dinner of pizza. You spread it out over a
full week and then there's two different kinds of Oreos that I eat cold. Those Oreos have been in there for six months. That sounds like my house. Nobody eats them. I never have. And there's all kinds of different honey toasted oats and Lucky Charms. And there was one dusty bag of unopened granola that I went ahead and enjoyed. I'm waiting to hear what the problem is. I know. So listen to this. Yeah. Well, no, yeah. So Sean and I were... You're hearing the problem is talking right now.
So Sean, you, by the way, we go over to a very nice respectable couple for dinner the other night. Okay. Well, you were there too. Yes. He wants a beverage with his dinner like most normal people. He goes looking in the fridge for one. There's all kinds of healthy drinks in there, some carbonated flavored soda-ish things. Not good enough for Sean and his titanium, you know, stomach. Nope. He wants a pure Coca-Cola.
That's right. And starts, he's opening up all kinds of cabinets and drawers and everything wondering, where's the Coke? Yeah. Like what's wrong with this house? One soft drink. I was looking for any soft drink. Soft drink is fine. And look, Richard went, it's our friend, Richard, who's a big listener on the program, and we love him to death.
We love him to death. Love him. So Richard went out of his way to find us drinks, et cetera. But again, the person who's the most upset about it is you, JB. Yeah. What's your relationship? Let's talk about that. Because you have such a knee-jerk reaction when it comes to talking about food and this kind of thing. Let's get into it a little bit.
Well, I was deprived of sugar, complex sugars, and most carbohydrates growing out. And do you love them? And I love them. Do you love them? I do love them, but my body loves them more. And so I have to, you know, keep them away from my body. Because as I've said multiple times, there's a 600-pound being just waiting to get out inside me. Our surprise guest has a fluffy cover over their camera.
Our surprise guest, they cover themselves with cashmere. Wow. Nice. This is a person who we all adore. I adore. This is somebody who's universally adored. I don't, you'd be pretty hard-pressed to find somebody who didn't have incredible things to say about this person. First of all, as a person, then as a performer, then just in every single way, this person, to me, epitomizes a great parent. They are a great performer. They are a great friend.
In fact, you can almost say that this person is one of America's best friends. This person is no one other... This is a friend-friend? ...than Courtney Cox. Courtney. Courtney. Courtney. Courtney.
Review yourself. Review yourself. Courtney. Hi, Courtney. Now, why is it taking so long? I feel like we have tried this... Well, we've had a few booking snafus with Courtney. She's been elusive a little bit. Like a little kitty cat. I just feel weird since I know you guys so well, but I don't know. Probably because maybe
we're just waiting to have something to talk about, or I don't know. It's kind of crazy though. What haven't we talked about? Because, listen, we all do gather at least once a week. Usually that's Courtney's fault, because she's so generous with her house and her time and her food. Without her, I think the glue would separate. Courtney, so you... Take your time. Take your time, Will. No, I'm trying to think where to start. You've done so many awesome things, and people will
know you from so many incredible things. Obviously, friends is just a worldwide sensation, the likes of which... Don't say, I don't.... The likes of which I've never been seen... God damn it, let him have his little phrases. But, you know, you've been part of our consciousness, sort of our cultural consciousness for a long time. For me, the thing that sticks out the most,
and this is one of my favorites, obviously, is Bruce Springsteen's Dancing in the Dark video, which we've talked about. And in fact, if you remember- But there's a bunch of people that listen to this that are younger than us that have no idea. No idea, so Bruce Springsteen had, when he had his- 1984 huge hit and Dancing in the Dark.
Born in the USA. Born in the, off the Born in the USA record. And in the video, Bruce is playing, and then he singles a girl out from the audience, and it's Courtney, and he brings her on stage, and they dance, and they do this iconic dance. And it's so great. Where was that, the Coliseum?
Yeah, it was, I think, in St. Paul. Oh, Minnesota, gotcha, okay. So Courtney, I don't know if you remember, so we were all on, remember we went on, we all went on vacation a few years ago with all the kids and everybody. And then I was in the gym, and you, I saw you coming, so I put on Dancing in the Dark.
And then we danced, do you remember? Oh, Jesus. And that was an iconic moment. But that, for me, I know, is so good. But I loved, that was when we first, I think like America first, like you became, and then you have been part of our collection, you've been part of, a huge part of the cultural fabric
since then, which is a long time. It is a long time. And what was that experience like for you? Was it, was that because music videos were so huge at that time? Yeah, that was when MTV first started, I think. Yeah, you know, I auditioned for that just like any other commercial,
and Brian De Palma directed it. He asked me to come into the room, not, this is not a weird thing, but all the people came into his office and we danced. Wow. And everyone, I walked into the room, everyone, these dancers were stretching, and I was like, oh no, I'm in the wrong place.
I'm not a ballerina, or I didn't know what was gonna happen. And so he said, well, you dance. And I probably was the same reaction that I got when he pulled me up on stage. I was completely nervous, even though I liked to dance. It, I was so uncomfortable. And then when I got to St. Paul, I just remember him, Brian De Palma had the flu,
so did Bruce Bingstein. It was his first night of tour, the first night he met, I'm not met, but sang with Patty Scaffa. Is that her name, Patty, say it? On stage. And there were three girls that were hired. And so when Brian said, okay,
so when Courtney goes on stage, and I was like, no, no, no, there's three of us. I do not wanna go on stage. Anybody else? She can, or she can't? I do not want to, and of course, that's probably the reason why they chose me. So when you auditioned and he said,
dance in my office, was it to that song? And were you dancing by yourself, or with him, Brian De Palma? No, I wish he'd stood up and danced. No, it was just me. By yourself, right? And it's my memory, right, that the iconic dance move that you were doing
is very similar to, I wanna say, Matthew Perry's dance move in the Friends Opening thing. Jason, have you seen Matthew dance in the opening? I was copying Bruce. Matthew, no offense. I hope he's listening, not listening. He, please watch it again. That's not.
But one of you dances in the same way, maybe? Or no, my memory is as bad as it was. It was very Miley Ringwald. Matt LeBlanc, maybe Matt LeBlanc does it. Well, I know that Schwimmer is really good. No, no, he does like a slow motion one or something, right? Or no, that's Schwimmer. Oh, yeah, Schwimmer does.
He does that kind of slow motion walk, and Bob's his head, and I think the girls, Lisa does her head shake thing, has one arm up. She's, they're all. So no one does the Bruce Springsteen dance in the opening. No, I was copying Bruce Springsteen. At one point, he does a turn all the way around, I think. And I thought, okay, I'm gonna just do this.
And I started going for the turn. I thought, no, you can't do this. And a turn back, I was too scared. Did you, but that was in front of a live crowd. Did you have to do multiple takes, or was it like a one take thing? Oh, no, that's right. We did, at the end of the song, he goes,
what do you do if you like something that much? And everybody said, do it again. And so they did, and they filmed it twice. Wow, wow. So, but it was in the middle of a concert, right? Yeah. Yeah, it was in the middle of a concert. And that song was just, was it on the radio yet,
even when you guys did that? I think so. That was his first number one single. Right, so it was huge. And it became number one because of the video, basically. I mean, that video was just on all the time. Yeah, all the time. It was like Michael Jackson's thriller,
and then Dancing in the Dark. They actually filmed a lot more than what was in it. And I remember watching, like we walked in, and we got t-shirts, and went to the bathroom, and put makeup on, and put our little muscle shirts on, and. Oh, wow. Wait, they shot all that?
That was part of it? They shot all this stuff. And then, so on the phone with my mom, as the video's premiering on MTV, it was a big deal. And I was like, mom, I got this video, and you're gonna see me? And it's like, I swear I'm coming on. And we waited, I'm only in the last 24 seconds.
I was kind of embarrassed about talking to my mom about it, but no one else knew, so I guess that was fine. So you auditioned for that as an actress, and then was there a bump from that that led to more and bigger opportunities in acting? Was it beneficial to you? Yeah, you know, I've always done things with people that everybody else wants to know about.
So if nothing else, people would want to see me because I was the girl in the Bruce Springsteen video, and everyone was like, how, what's Bruce really like? And then I did Family Ties. I was like, what's Michael J. Fox really like? And then I did Friends, and it was like, what's Jennifer Anderson really like? What, well, wait, what was,
so talk to me a bit about your Family Ties experience, because obviously somebody who's close to our show has a connection to Family Ties as well. All right. Sean? What's up, JP? Did I ever see you there? I wonder, did I?
You must have. Well, I don't. Because I would go there after I would get wrapped from my show, because I would get off earlier because I was younger, and then I remember doing my homework in the stands, watching Justine finish up rehearsals. Jason, tell Tracy what, your connection?
My sister was on Family Ties. She played Mallory. Right. And then so Courtney, you came onto Family Ties. What season was that? The last two years. Last two years. And what was that experience like?
Because Family Ties was huge. It was a huge, massive hit. I loved it. Followed the Cosby show, I think, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah. I think so. That was nerve-wracking, because being a guest star, first of all, they've been doing it forever,
and they're so comfortable, and it's just like second nature to them. But it was a big deal for me. And coming on, I just remember, you remember the character Skippy? Yeah, yeah. Well, we called ourselves the B players. And Scott Valentine, was that, am I saying that?
I think so. And we would always say, oh, the B players are here. And for some reason, you kind of felt like you had to start over each time, because you might not be in for three episodes, and then it was like the first time again. But Gary David Goldberg was the nicest man in the world,
the creator of the show. This was the boss of the show, yeah. And then also Michael J. Fox, it's just so sweet. He was already married at that point, and he, to the other girlfriend, Tracy Pollan, who was on Before Me, and she was really sweet. Oh my God, that's right. Have you ever,
you know, like when you are a regular on a show, and you have guest stars come in, it's almost like having a guest at your house, right? It's something because it's your home, it's your workplace, and you have this relationship with everybody. Has there ever been an experience where you guest on a show like Family Tizer,
anytime in your life, you don't have to say what the show is, or who the people are, where you didn't have a welcoming feeling, and you were like, this doesn't feel good. And you know what, when I have a show, when I'm a regular, I'm gonna turn this around and make everybody feel welcome,
which goes back to the caretaking thing when people go to your house. Oh, okay, well, I don't, I have to think about the guest starring thing. Because I don't think I've ever been comfortable, not that people haven't been nice, but I don't think they reach out as much as I did, and you're right.
So on Friends, first of all, we have run-throughs on Wednesdays, or we did, I love that I'm still on the show, it's been 15, 20 years, I don't know. But when we have our run-throughs on Wednesday, so many people would get fired. Oh, really? Like friends of mine.
Really? Yeah, and I would feel, I would always feel so bad, because they only had one shot at doing a rehearsal, and then Wednesday, the network would come through, and that would be it. Yeah. And so I would either send flowers, or I would call,
I felt so bad for them. Oh, that's very nice. I know, it sounds really stupid, but. But can you imagine the pressure? Well, you, I was gonna say, can you imagine, of course you can, because you went on Family Ties, which was a huge hit as a guest,
and so you know that pressure, but can you imagine going to Friends, and being a guest star, and you have like one scene, and you've got like five lines, and you've got to score at that run-through in front of the network, and the pressure of the,
not just the number one show on TV, the number one show on the planet, and guess what, dude, if you don't hit it, like that must have been, I went out and I did Sean's show, Will and Grace, years ago. They tried to fire him so hard. And they tried so hard,
and Jimmy Burroughs was the only one who said, nah, give him another chance, honey. But I knew that pressure. Will and Grace at that time was a top five, top 10 show. It was like a massive hit, and I was like, well, better be good. It's so true. It's scary as a performer.
You scored big time. And all these movie actors would come on, and they would be so nervous, but of course they would never be fired, but. No. And we will be right back. Court, you know what I love? I saw you cooking, and I was like, and everything.
I love that. I love it. I'm like obsessed with your, whenever you have an Instagram post about you cooking, because you do the thing that where you, it's like, look, it's really easy. You just chop this up, you do this, you do this. And I was like, first of all,
where did the love come from? Why is it so exciting for me? It's so entertaining. I can't take my eyes off it. And what do you get out of it? So wait, what is this? You're talking to a granddad that doesn't have, or not on the Instagram.
Oh, she could. It's like live recipes. No, she takes you through the process of cooking. Courtney, you tell us. Okay, so when lockdown happened, I, my hobbies just went through the roof. I started cooking every single night. I started playing the piano more,
or, you know, got pretty decent at it. Yeah, very good. Played tennis. I really did a lot of stuff. And then I, for some reason, Instagram, which takes up so much time. I don't know why I, I don't know why do I have to do these little videos?
Why can't I just be the person that posts the sunset? No, I have to edit them and put music to them. It's just so stupid. But anyway, yeah, cooking has been great. I just, well, I really take someone else's recipe and either simplify it or act like it's really easy. Courtney, Courtney, what I love, you touch on, you mentioned something which is great.
First of all, you're cooking. You should know Courtney gave me this great home, sort of steak sauce recipe, which was, and Courtney, I don't want to take it away from you. You tell us what it is. Because I still use it. I told you that I still use it to this day. She told me.
It's called cream of mushroom soup. It's a bachelor's gravy. No, no, listen. The bachelor's gravy. What is cream of mushroom? Is the bachelor's? Cream of mushroom soup, yeah, from a Campbell's can. It's the bachelor's gravy.
Oh yeah, I love a can. And I like my cranberry sauce at Thanksgiving. I want to see the ridges, because I think that's cute. But I get that. My dad used to make a sauce and it would be Heinz 57 mostly. That's the main ingredient.
A1 Worcestershire sauce, however you say that. And just a little bit of ketchup. Yeah. It's a really good sauce. It's incredible. And to this day, years ago, Courtney's like, this is what you need to use, blah, blah, blah. I did it incredible to this day.
I still use it. So I love that. So thank you. Great tip. And if you're out there, let us know. We'll read it in the comments. Well, do you have any desire to cook? You don't cook, do you?
I don't. I do have that desire, but it feels like, I wish I knew. It's one of those things. I wish I knew how to cook. I wish I knew how to play piano. And this is what I was going to get to. It kind of feeds right into,
Courtney, you're talking about like you, when you focus on stuff, you get into it. So like tennis you mentioned, you're a really good tennis player. You're like, and you're very modest about everything that you do. You've got really good at piano. You're good at cooking.
You're kind of good at everything because you focus on it and you spend the time on it. Where does that come from? Like that kind of, you have that great discipline. I said it before, you're very disciplined. I think that because we've had so much time, but I really have pretty bad ADD. So if I take a piano lesson, it's not one hour.
It's four hours because we get up. I go off and do something. It's never really focused, but I do stick with stuff. And I do love the piano so much. I love it, love it, love it. It's brought a lot of joy. And I've actually, did you see that post where I played with Elton John?
Yes. Yes, that was crazy. I mean, do you understand the thrill that was? It was insane. It was holding my arm. And I was like, wait, I don't, I don't, I won't get to hold my arm, but how am I going to play?
I'm so nervous. And Brandy Carlyle was singing behind me and Ed was next to me. But that was Ed's idea to do that. It was the song, Hold Me Closer, Kind Dancer. Ed Sheeran. Oh, sorry. No, it's for my sister.
So we did the song to Lisa Kujo, Hold Me Closer, Tony Danza. And Lisa does a post back and says, I really like the song, but it's not, it's Hold Me Close, Young Tony Danza. We got it wrong. She's so funny. That's hilarious.
But you've had these incredible Sunday night soirees. So you talk about the family, but also, like you said, you have like skits. It's a little different from your grandmother's house where everybody's doing a skit. I was there once in Taylor Swift, played in your living room, or, you know, like just like crazy Ed Sheeran, et cetera, et cetera.
It goes on. Music is so important to you. Obviously, Johnny, your boyfriend is an incredible musician, songwriter, performer, everything. That's a really, do you feel like you missed your calling a little bit? If I was really good, I would have been for sure in music and been in a band.
I just wish I'd started earlier, not started when I'm 50. Well, that's what I mean. Like you, did it like, did it hit you like, oh gosh, I should have done, this was what I should have been doing. Cause it brings you so much to life. I love it.
Yeah, exactly. I wish I was a musician, a real one. That's how I actually, yeah, Sunday nights have been great. That's how I met Johnny is that he was brought over by Ed. You summoned him. Yeah. Yeah, you did.
It just happened, yeah. The universe, the universe served him up. We believe in that. You know, I believe in that. Well, you could, I mean, you've got plenty of time. You could sort of, you could weave some music into the next chapter in your career. I mean, what would that do, right?
What would be the natural transition to that? That would be, if you were in a punk band, like a really, if you played heavy metal, you guys could be called Courtney and the Hardcocks. And I'm just saying, no, because it would be a heavy, like really. Yeah, that would be good. I'd listen to that.
But Court, would you ever write stuff or would you ever like challenge yourself? I wrote one song about, it's so many years ago. With Johnny? No, I've never written a song with Johnny. No. Johnny has written like so many huge hits. It's insane.
Tell my sister who Johnny is. Okay, so Johnny McDade is in Snow Patrol, but really as another, not his side job, but an incredible part of his career is that he writes with Ed. He wrote Bad Habits, I mean, yes, Bad Habits, but he also wrote Shape of You. He's written with Ed, probably 90% of his last album
and even other ones in the past. Amazing. He also wrote Like What About Us with Pink and he wrote Underdog with Alicia Keys. But he writes with people all the time. Louis Capaldi, he's just incredible. He's a poet. Have you ever talked to him about maybe writing
a song with him? Well, what am I gonna do once I have it? I can't sing. Yes, you can. No, no, no, but you can just be a songwriter, like participate in his songwriting endeavors. Like, does he ever like run some lyrics by you and you go, oh, but what if you say X, Y, and Z?
And he goes, oh, Courtney, that's great. Oh, sorry. Hey, guys, accent alert. Here we go. Guys, Johnny's here. Oh, Tarp of the Merni-Tier. You didn't want to just throw in Lucky Charms while you're at it.
How offensive. I did. I wrote one song, I mean, one line of a song and a birdie song, it's called Wild Horses. And I was thinking that song was very much like I Will Survive by Gloria Gaynor. And so one of the lines was, I will not beg you to stay. And that was my contribution to that song.
Oh, wow. But I will say Johnny doesn't sound as much like an Irish leprechaun who's that bad to say I'm canceled now. Okay, as he's from Northern Ireland, it's the hardest accent to do. Can you, do you do it, Johnny? Of course, got it.
Courtney? I mean, it's now is, no, it's so hard, yeah. Hey, Will, have you ever tried to do Johnny? Let's hear it, let's hear it. No. That's pretty good. Courtney, are you there? No.
That's really good. It's not bad, it's not bad. So I mean, yeah, he's just such a mega talent and so that must, that being, having that sort of in your life, must be so satisfying like that. Yeah, it is. Because you guys are always,
he's always creating and you're creating and you get to, you're in that thing. I mean, that's exhilarating. It would be like, it would be like, I'd have to marry Shani, I guess. That would be the equivalent. Brendan Shanahan, friend of the show. Well, now, Court, can we talk about the challenges
of being in love with somebody who's a half a planet away? That is challenging. Yeah, he lives in London and I live here. He spent a lot of time on FaceTime and for some reason I have the worst internet in the world. So half the time it's just not working. And because he's so technological and I'm not,
I don't know how to fix anything. I just go, I don't know. And that seems to be our biggest conflict is our FaceTime. What you guys do get to be in person. Reboot, reboot the router. Turn it off, turn it on. Turn off the router.
Started again. But how often do you see him? How often do you not see him? Like, what's the ratio? Jesus, guys, we're getting really, then on a very special smart list. Yeah, no, we're getting personal. Oh, no, I just, well,
okay, we didn't see each other very much during the first part of the lockdown. Even when I could have, I was with my brother and he was riding with Ed up in Suffolk and that was kind of tough. But now I go there a lot. I feel like I go there once a month or he doesn't come here as much.
Just because I think, well, first of all, he was opened up in November to America, to people outside of the UK. Right, right, right. So yeah, I go there a lot. But for a while, because of COVID, he was like, don't even go there. Yeah, I mean, it was just hard.
He couldn't come here and I was busy with my brother. What about, are you, have you ever thought about moving to England or has he ever thought about moving here? Well, he used to live here. We lived together a long time ago and then he moved to London because we broke up for a little while and then,
but once Coco goes to school, that will be a whole other thing. We could spend much more time together. You've been keeping her out of school all this whole time? You're gonna get arrested for that. Coco's going to school, right? Like college. Yeah, she got into her one choice.
That's great. Nice. Yeah. That's great. I know, it's really exciting. Now, how are you gonna, just to keep you sad, how are you gonna deal with it when Courtney goes away to school?
Have you have a strategy? I ask only because, what did I say? Courtney. Oh yeah, when Coco goes, because I'm asking only because I've already started thinking about my strategy with Franny and Maple. It's not going to be easy for me to be an empty nester. No.
Are you going to follow her, do you think? Or are you just going to wallpaper your house with pictures of her? Well, you know, my sister, it was so hard for her when her kid, her last kid went off. And then I think of Johnny's sister, she started getting really upset the year before. I think Coco's prepping me, she's never home.
She's always in her room. So I don't even know if I'm gonna, like I'll miss a couple of things she does, they'll come into my room and we'll snuggle every now and then for a minute, then she'll say, can I go to someone's house when she's prepping? She's always prepping me for something. And I don't know, I'd love to maybe get a place
or just be around her when she goes to college. And maybe buy a bunch of cats just to kind of compensate. Do you find yourself, you're always busy with work. I was gonna get back. So do you think that work will, when Coco does go, that you'll just kind of maybe occupy yourself a lot? And you're always, again, you're always very busy. You're doing a lot of stuff.
You've got a new show coming out on Starz soon, right? What's the show? It's called Shining Veil. It's on Starz airs March the sixth. I think that the last year has been the busiest year of my life. I'm starting a product line with Jason. I know, you know, cause you smell a lot of the stuff,
the candles and you've given me good opinions. Let's take those by the number. So you're doing the new show on Starz. Talk a little bit about what it is. Okay, so the show is, it's got Greg Keneer and Mira Sovino and Gus Bernie and I always panic. You can come back. Jake Dylan.
And it's great. It's about a woman who was going through menopause and well, I should, why didn't I just say midlife crisis? Why don't I have to go to menopause, but... Yeah, you see whatever you want. It's both. And she has an affair with the handyman. She wants to start her life over
and they moved to Connecticut into a haunted house. And only the only person that can see the ghost is me and everybody else thinks I'm psycho. So it's a comedy, but it's also, it's a thriller. And that's kind of a genre of bending thing because it's not a comedy like Scream where Scream is, it's a slasher. By the way, congratulations on Scream.
Scream is a huge hit right now. Huge hit. So you've had, I was gonna say this. So you've actually had a lot of success in that kind of like, I know that Scream is kind of over the top and it's a comedy, but it's also a scary... Genre. Yeah, genre.
But that, is that something that you've always been attracted to or you've thought about? I'm not really like horror films, but I mean, I have, that was my fifth one to do. But I do like to be, I mean, I love to be, well, I shouldn't say this because then people will scare me and I don't really like to be scared.
So what I think I do, I like those kind of movies. What if I was doing the zoom from the next room right next to you? You mean like, what if the podcast was coming from inside the house? Well, I will say after I saw this last Scream, I'm certain Ghostface is somewhere, I would like to go up,
if the dogs wake up in the middle of the night, I'm so scared because it's dark and I don't really know. I take a flashlight, but I'm certain someone's gonna jump out. Yeah. We will be right back. Do you have any funny fears? Like I got one about bees.
I just can't, bees, just wreck my day. Bees? Bees? Bees. Bees. Bees. Bees. Do you have like, are you, do you look under the bed? Do you avoid walking under ladders? Do you, do you have a fear of earthquakes?
Like what's your funny fear? I think my fear would be of birds. Birds? I don't like things flapping around me. Birds, birds. Yeah, or like a bird, if there's a crow outside, cause those are big, those crows, I'm certain they're gonna come peck me.
Birds are dinosaurs, closer than lizards are. Oh, thanks doctor. So, uh, Sean, what's your funny fear? My funny fear. Oh boy, here we go. There's a two hour episode.
What is it? I guess. Women, there we go. Will. Jesus. I fear nothing. And back to Courtney. No, wait, what is my fear?
My fear is, I have a fear of bees a little bit. I have a little, I understand the bird thing. Mine's gotten better. What's that? I'm sorry, mine's gotten better, but it's still there. Go ahead, birds you can relate to as well. Yeah, what is my fear? Spiders?
No, I don't fear spiders. Cockroaches, cockroaches, rats. I don't know. How about food that is moldy that you can't see until you're chewing it? Oh. I have a fear. I gotta always check the strawberries,
check the blueberries. That's weird that it's food-related. Fuck me, man. I have a fear of losing gas in my car, of like driving and not looking down at this and being- You drive a Tesla. No, I don't. Scotty, no.
You've got no gas in your car. How about a spider in the toilet? A spider in the toilet. It's gonna crawl up your ass. Yeah, I had this fear for years and years and years and years based on nothing and then last year. Again, the universe delivered it. There was a spider in my toilet and I was like,
I thought I was just being a freak. It really can happen. No, cause you thought about it long enough. If you think about something, the universe will deliver it. Hang on guys, everyone listening? Go ahead. What about those centipedes,
this one with all the little legs? You know, talking about the longs? I once found a centipede in the house I was renting in New Mexico where it's lousy with centipedes and it was in the middle of the night. I was watching a Dodger game at like 2.30 in the morning. I saw this little thing skitter across the floor and there was, my mattress was on the floor in this house.
So I knew I had to find the centipede if I had any hope of getting any rest. Sounds like you were holed up. Were you like in a hostage situation with a mattress on the floor in New Mexico? It wasn't a high end dreadful. The bathtub full of math. Were you cooking?
It took me so long to find the centipede. When I finally did, I stamped down on it so hard with my heel that I bruised my heel. I couldn't walk straight for a week. Wait, wait, did you wear shoes to do this? I had slippers on, you know me. And Christian had slippers on.
Yeah, it was so nice. I had a friend of mine had a silver fish in his ear. Ooh, that is really nice. He had to go. He was like, why don't I have like a little bit of a headache? He went to and they pulled it out of his ear and it went in there when he was sleeping from his bed. Have you ever seen that thing?
Don't look a bot fly on YouTube. Have you ever seen a bot fly? No. Yeah, they're in the jungles of like Central and South America and they go and they burrow into your skull and then they reproduce. And so these people, like you see these videos of people who go back to England, they go to their doctor like,
Maya, go something that's sought of me at, haven't I? And then they go and they're like, and then this thing just, they pull out. Hey, Will, what website are you, what website have you been going to lately? We wrote a scene once for, we did that show, Running Wild Mitch and I, Hurwitz and Jimmy Valley.
Holds for a pause. Yeah, we wrote this scene where we wanted to have David Cross is being held in like a quarantine because he's got a bot fly in his living in his head. That's funny. Courtney, what do you, but what's your number one fear? Would you say? Not just funny fear, real fear.
Yeah, is it anything about working? Like, do you fear not working? Do you love to work? Or do you have the perfect work-life balance now? Do you wish one was, well, don't, you're on her leading the way. I was asking. Maybe it's something to do in her personal life.
Maybe she's, it's not all about Hollywood haze. Hollywood haze, how do we ever thought of that? It's a new podcast. Well, I know people. What would be my biggest fear? Maybe that anything to do with Coco, like her not- Health of the kids. Something, yeah.
Or actually, Coco's heart. Yeah. I mean, I think she's, you think I'm a caretaker? Oh my God, Coco is the biggest caretaker. And then I always worry, I worry about her. That she's going to care for the wrong person? Or not about guys or relationships, but more about her, even just her friends.
Right. Hang on, Will's got a joke, go for it. As I say, Jason's biggest fear is living it out to the right on number four and being OB. What does that mean? Right? It's golf-related. It's out of bounds on the right side of the four-fairway.
So, all right, so court. Now let's get out of fear and sadness and empty nesting. Now let's get into her product line, which I wanted to do, because that was the other thing. So you're so busy, which kind of goes to Sean, what you were saying, like, do you, is this because you have a fear of, where does that drive of like,
what was doing stuff? The fear of not smelling nice. No, but like, you've got like a million shows, and the reason I asked you, too, is because you produced this show, you produced Cougar Town, you've produced a lot of stuff that you've done, like you've always got so many things,
and now you've added on this personal, how do you describe it, personal Caroline? Well, no, it's not, it's more of a home line, it's called home court. Nice. Like home court advantage, home court. Oh my God. That's really great.
But, so I love scents, and it's like, I love to mix oils and perfume. I love that. So I wanted to start a candle company, and then I thought, we spend so much time at home, and at first, of course, all of the smell of Clorox when we first locked down. But then I thought, once things,
we didn't have to wipe out our packages, and all that stuff. I thought, why not have your home, like room spray, a counter spray, your dish soap, or your hand soap, and what smell like the way you'd want your, it's called beauty products for the home, essentially. And it's all recycled plastic,
it's all, we got a chemist that does makeup. That's how it's approved for everything. So not, I'm not saying spray it in your face, like an atomizer, or what's it called? Toner. Spritzer. But if it got on your- Jason wants to see the carb count
before he sprays that on his face. Yeah, will it make me puffy if I spray it on my face? Do not do that, but it's safe for everything. And it smells so good. And there's four scents. You could basically have one scent that goes through your whole house, whether it be your dishwashing soap,
your hand soap, your room spray. No, but what if you want to mix, you don't want one scent, you want to mix it up. Yeah, there's four scents, but each scent goes through all the product lines. So you may want to wash your dishes with rose, and you may want your room to have a candle that is my signature scent,
which I think smells incredible. It's kind of smoky slash. I love that idea. Do you see yourself expanding because you do love design and architecture and all that stuff? Do you see yourself getting and expanding that into doing like home furnishings and stuff like that?
Like I think that you would put it this way. If you had a line of stuff, I'd be like, well, I'm going to do what Courtney does. I mean, anything can happen because once you have a company called Home Court, you could do anything. I mean, we could expand to whether it's laundry pods to, I mean, that would be great.
I love to make sheets because I'm obsessed with sheets. Well, Sean needs a new set. Yeah, he sure does. I don't sheet myself, get it? So Courtney, what's on tap for you for the rest of the day? What's your life like right now? What do you do?
Tell them you're busy. Tell them you're busy. The D to D, the D to D. All right, I'm going to go into town and box. I'm going to, I'm going to go to a dermatologist because I had this weird thing on top of my head and it was like a little- It could be a butterfly, it could be a butterfly.
Oh, shit. I better check that. And then I'm going to go with Amanda, by the way. Yeah, yeah. I'm going to go, well, I'm going to go like, oh, I'm going to go to the gym equipment place first because I want to buy some home gym equipment. You've got a great home gym.
You're adding to it? Yeah, you've got so much more. I want like a machine that can do things. I need to- Gotcha. Now, you know, Will's, Will Box is with the fight camp. I do. Oh, you do?
Every day. Get one of those fight camp things in your gym. You don't have to drive into the city to box. Courtney, it has been- What's a fight camp? It's been a game changer. Our buddy, we have a friend of the show is a, who sometimes writes in questions,
a JT out of New York. And he's got a- Justin T. He's sleeve challenged. Let's just say that. He's sleeve challenged. Yeah, poor guy. And he turned me on to this thing fight camp
about a year ago. No, six months ago. And it's so good. And it's like a, you know, there's like a whole program. You can do it like on your laptop or your thing. And then you have a heavy bag and you do the, you know, I did eight rounds this morning. When do they tell you to expect results?
Well- We're all dying. Oh boy. No, seriously, Court, you could go over to Will's place. You guys could do boxing sessions together. You guys could do like a little ring. Come look at my setup. It's so good.
Come with Amanda. Well, I'm not, I'm going to be playing golf today with our friends from Callaway. Oh yeah. What's Callaway? Now these people from Callaway, thank you, Callaway. They are, they're very generous. Is that a golf course?
It's a golf company. Hashtag rogue. The new stuff is pretty good. And they sent us some new stuff and it's really nice. And we didn't even, this is not a paid thing. We just, they just sent us some golf gloves. Hey, let me ask you something. Sean doesn't want to come play.
Do you, do you have to buy your own golf balls or do they give them to you when you go? They are nice enough to give us some golf balls. Okay. They give us golf balls too. But generally a person you go and you buy golf balls. Yeah. Cause I gave you some golf balls, Jay, for Christmas.
I just didn't know. Yeah, no, I have those. Yeah. Yeah. That's a weird way to say thanks. Yeah. I have those. What a funny, what a funny twist on thank you.
Wait, so Courtney. And it's a funny twist. So Courtney, you're going to go, you're going to go and do what I love about it is talking about self care. You're going to do it. You're going to do workout. You're going to get some gym equipment.
You're going to get, you're going to get a dermatologist like. And then I'm going to hang out with Jason's wife. I mean, what are you doing with my wife? And is it going to benefit me at all? Are you guys shopping for me? Well, she's going to get some food. So maybe she'll bring it home. That's helpful.
But we're going to go visit Nicole. Okay. Nicole Levant. Yeah. And you guys are going to go buy some yummy food. Jason, oh, you guys are going to have some yummy cardboard. Can't wait gluten-free or something to call it. There's a hummus bread on there.
By the way, I like gluten-free bread more than regular bread. It's chewier. It has better texture with gluten-free. Thank you for that. Incredible. I'm gluten-free. What kind of bread do you use? Anything gluten-free.
Gluten-free pizza is real yummy, too. Oh, yeah. Oh, you've convinced yourself that's good, too. Yeah. Have you guys tried quinoa? This is cool. Have you tried regular just everyday food? Jason, no, I'm trying to hit 100, Sean.
I want to get to 100. I'm not happy with 65. So Courtney, anyway, gosh, I mean, we could just keep going forever. We could hang, I didn't even realize that we're over the time. We've taken up way too much of your time. Yeah. We just love talking.
What do you have a tea time, Will? You got to get out to the range? No, I actually don't, not yet. And we- But Courtney does. She does. We love talking to you. Spending time with you is just the best.
You're such an awesome person as we, I'm going to end the same way that we started. So thanks for coming and hanging with us. Yeah. Thank you. I don't get to see you enough these days. So I miss hanging out. I don't feel like we did an episode today.
That just feels like just normal chat because we're all so close, which I guess means it's great. Yeah. Thanks, guys. I'm so glad to be on the show. I really, all three of you, looking at your, just like friends. Thank you, honey.
Yeah, well, good luck. Listen, good luck with your show. Very, very looking forward to it. I can't wait to watch it. Tell us the date again when it starts on- March the 6th. March the 6th. March the 6th.
And the line came out on January 26th. Home court. And I want a free dozen candles. If you don't go and buy a home court, no, no, no, not free, she's starting a business. All right. Go buy a dozen candles. Go get a friend's rate.
Thank you, Courtney. We love you. Thanks, Courtney. Love you, honey. Courtney, love you. Bye, sweetie. Bye, Courtney. Just slam it, slam it.
Slam the laptop. Slam it. Yeah, yeah. How great is Courtney? And I know that I sort of started and ended the same way, but she's such a great person. Always made me feel warm and welcome anytime I see her or anytime I was over at her house, yeah.
Really funny, really sweet. Really cool and very considerate. Not affected by her success or from... At all. She is of the arts. At all. Yeah, I love it. Yeah, I don't have anything nice to say.
Huh. That's funny, because she entertains you a lot. Like you go and stay at her house quite often. Listen, she is a single mom that has an incredible daughter and is incredibly, they're both so happy and fulfilled in their life. They've got an incredible group of friends around them. It's in such a sort of star-filled sort of world
that brings all of its sort of complexities and challenges and all of that garbage. Sheila's a very normal life, which is great. Yeah, she leads a deserved, charmed life. You know what it's also funny? Dax and I used to always joke about this, that we joke like the greatest compliment that we'd be like sort of foe humbled by
as if somebody said like, he's a great guy and he's just an incredible friend. What a friend. We'd be like, oh, like I have this sort of false modesty. Like, oh, thank you. Thank you. But she is the epitome of that. Yeah, for sure.
She is such a great friend to so many people. And she's kind of one of those people that if anybody's going through anything, you're not surprised when they go like, I called Courtney. You're like, yeah, of course. Of course you called Courtney. She's gonna give you good advice and she's gonna listen and she's gonna be kind and thoughtful
and loving and warm. She's gonna be there for you. Yeah, yeah, because I have a friend, he's like, my job's a joke, I'm broke. My love life's DOA. I feel like I'm always stuck in second gear when it hasn't been my day, my week, my month, or even my year.
Wait, are those the lyrics to the, come on. Oh, hey, Jason, I just got a text from 1994. Wait a second, is that truly the lyrics of the song? Yes, that's the song of different friends. Good God. Don't you think they should bring the whole cast back, not call it, not a reboot of friends, call it enemies, right, so they've gotten older
and now they're just assholes to each other. Don't you think that would be funny? Yeah. No. Enemies, no. Terrible idea. Yeah, but pitch it around town and see what you get. You know what I wanna say to you?
What's that? Bye. Oh. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted
by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett Barbaco. Smart. Less. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon Music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.